[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen und Fußball hat
Norbert Lehmann für sich einen schönen
guten Tag und wir schauen unter anderem
in die USA Donald Trump auf der
Anklagebank der frühere US-Präsident
plädiert auf nicht schuldig und holt
dann zum Rundumschlag gegen die Justiz
aus
was tun gegen die medikamentenmangel
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach will die
Produktion von Arzneimitteln attraktiver
machen und mehr Vorräte schaffen
und Viertelfinale im DFB-Pokal nach dem
spektakulären aus von Bayern gegen
Freiburg empfängt Leipzig heute Dortmund
er ist der erste ehemalige US-Präsident
gegen den Anklage erhoben wurde während
die Staatsanwaltschaft Donald Trump
kriminelles Verhalten im Zuge von
schweigegeldzahlungen an eine
Pornodarstellerin vorwirft spricht Trump
selbst von massiver Wahlbeeinflussung er
will erneut Präsidentschaftskandidat der
Republikaner werden für die Wahlen im
nächsten Jahr mehr von Claudia Bates
am Ende des Tages ist Donald Trump
wieder da wo er sich am wohlsten fühlt
vor treuen Anhängern in seinem
Anwesenden Florida hier hat er die
Kontrolle auch über die Lesart dieses
ereignisreichen Tages und beschimpft
trotz einer Warnung des Richters den New
Yorker Staatsanwalt als Verbrecher den
Richter als Trump Hasser
jetzt wollen diese linksradikalen
verrückten mit der Justiz die Wahlen
beeinflussen das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
hier war Trump machtlos die Tür fällt
einfach zu hier ist ihm niemand zu
Diensten im Gericht in New York ist eher
nicht Herdes Geschehens was ihm
sichtlich Unbehagen bereitet in 34
Fällen habe er betrügerisch
Geschäftsunterlagen gefälscht um
kriminelles Verhalten zu verbergen drei
schweigegeldzahlungen um vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2016 schädliche
Informationen vor den Wählern zu
verheimlichen so die Staatsanwaltschaft
heute sind wir unserer Verantwortung
gerecht geworden dass jeder vor dem
Gesetz gleich ist weder viel Geld noch
viel Macht ändern diesen beständigen
amerikanischen Grundsatz
der Angeklagte Donald Trump plädierte
auf nicht schuldig und kam anschließend
ohne Auflagen frei Trump oder Tod
draußen auf den Straßen New Yorks war
Zirkus die befürchteten Unruhen blieben
aus die Polizei trennte die Gegner
Trumps und seiner Anhänger durch
Absperrungen und stellte so sicher dass
sie nur mit Worten kämpften der Prozess
gegen Donald Trump wird voraussichtlich
im Januar nächsten Jahres beginnen
also noch gut neun Monate bis der
Prozess beginnt MRT Wissen Trump will ja
wieder Präsidentschaftskandidat werden
nützt oder schadet ihm da diese
Strafverfahren
also Donald Trumps Umfragewerte sind
erstmal in die Höhe geschnellt er hat
sogar den Abstand vor größer zu
möglichen anderen
präsidentschaftsbewerbern innerhalb
seiner eigenen Partei der Grund ist ganz
einfach 90% der Republikaner glauben
dass diese Anklage politische Verfolgung
ist und dann war nicht einmal die
Gegenkandidaten in der Lage sich gegen
ihn zu stellen sie mussten ihn
verteidigen das ist der sogenannte Rally
round the Flagge Effekt man schaut sich
um die Flagge in diesem Fall den
Anführer wenn er angegriffen wird aber
ein Team von uns war gestern an der
republikanischen Basis und da hat man
natürlich auch eine positive Stimmung zu
Donald Trump erlebt aber auch ein
Pragmatismus wenn es weitere Anklagen
gibt und das ist sehr wahrscheinlich
wenn sein Wahlkampf darunter leidet und
wenn er politisch nicht mehr zu bieten
hat als ich immer nur als Opfer
darzustellen sind Sie bereit auch einen
anderen Kandidaten zu unterstützen zum
Beispiel ronde sanche von Florida
genauso konservativ aber viel weniger
Drama vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
und Eindrücke Emotionen
Lieferengpässe für Medikamente sind nach
wie vor ein drängendes Problem das
zuständige Bundesinstitut für
Arzneimittel zählt aktuell hunderte
Medikamente die nur eingeschränkt zur
Verfügung stehen darunter sind auch
Mittel gegen Krebs Antibiotika und
Blutdrucksenker die Bundesregierung will
nun ein Gesetz das neue Preis Regeln
vorsieht das Ziel Deutschland soll
wieder konkurrenzfähig werden beim
Einkauf und bei der Produktion wichtiger
Wirkstoffe Heikes lanski
die Rats-Apotheke in Flensburg im Moment
tobt im Norden eine scharlachwelle
dagegen würde Penicillin helfen für
Kinder und Erwachsene doch ausgerechnet
dieses Antibiotikum ist derzeit
Mangelware kein neues Phänomen das
Problem hausgemacht denn gesetzlich
festgelegte Verträge haben Preise nach
unten gedrückt diese Rabattverträge
haben einfach zu einem ruinösen
Preiswettbewerb geführt und deswegen ist
es für die Arzneimittelhersteller nicht
lukrativ hier Arzneimittel
zu verkaufen also gehen Sie lieber
woanders hin ob Antibiotika Krebs oder
Kinderarzneimittel immer wieder Engpässe
in deutschen Apotheken und das schon
seit längerem die Gründe Lieferengpässe
aus Asien kaum noch Hersteller in Europa
das soll sich mit gelockerten
Preisregeln nun ändern Beispiel
kindermedikamente
da setzen wir die Festbeträge aus da
setzen wir die Rabattverträge aus und
für die bestehenden Preise erlauben wir
den Unternehmen eine
Marktanpassung im Sinne einer
Preissteigerung von 50%. mehr Geld für
Präparate Vorräte anlegen dadurch soll
die Produktion in Europa wieder
angekurbelt werden finanzielle Anreize
für die Pharmaindustrie die der
Versicherte zu tragen hätte kritisieren
Kassenvertreter mit diesem Gesetz wird
es teurer das heißt die beitragszahlerin
sie und ich über unsere
Krankenkassenbeiträge werden höhere
Gewinne für die fahrmanindustrie
bezahlen ohne dass die Versorgung der
Kranken Menschen besser wird
Ziel Kritik an Lauterbachs Gesetzentwurf
fortsetzung folgt im Bundestag
und auch ein weiteres Problem im
Gesundheitswesen will die Regierung
angehen die Engpässe bei der Pflege das
Kabinett hat dazu die angekündigte
Pflegereform auf den Weg gebracht sie
sieht unter anderem eine Erhöhung des
Pflegegeldes um 5% vor dafür wird von
Juli an der Pflegebeitrag angehoben für
Menschen mit einem Kind steigt der von
derzeit 3,05% des Bruttoeinkommens auf
3,4 Prozent Eltern mit mehreren Kindern
zahlen je nach Anzahl der Kinder weniger
für Kinderlose steigt der von jetzt 3,4%
auf 4%
. beim Treffen der nato-außenministerin
und Minister ging es heute vor allem um
den Umgang mit China
weigere sich Russlands Aggression zu
verurteilen und Stütze Russlands
Wirtschaft sonato Generalsekretärs
solltenberg wegen des russischen
Angriffskrieges hat sich das
Militärbündnis ja gerade vergrößert aus
Brüssel berichtet Florian neuhahn
am Tag nach der Aufnahme seines Landes
wirkt es schon bei einer wie Alltag der
finnische Außenminister mittendrin bei
der NATO der gleich den Ton setzt für
das Thema des heutigen Tages
wir sind sehr besorgt dass China
Russland weitere Hilfe beim Krieg gegen
die Ukraine zukommen lässt
China und Russland ist es dieser
Schulterschluss politisch wie mit
solchen militärischen Übungen der den
Westen umtreibt und es ist der
Nato-Generalsekretär der heute
deutlicher warnt als zuvor
die Lieferung von Waffen durch China an
Russland wäre ein historischer Fehler
mit weitreichenden Folgen
derweil sucht die NATO selbst Verbündete
und findet diese vier Australien Japan
Neuseeland Südkorea die sich selbst
bedroht sehen von Chinas Macht streben
und die sich heute in Brüssel genauso
äußern wie die Gastgeber
sollte seinen Einfluss auf Russland
nutzen damit es diesen Krieg beendet
seine Truppen zurückzieht und es
ernsthafte Friedensverhandlungen mit der
Ukraine geben kann
China ist der Schlüssel und der Westen
richtet einen Blick auf die Welt macht
im Osten heute Ankunft des französischen
Staatspräsidenten in Peking wo er morgen
zusammen mit der
eu-kommissionspräsidentin mit dem
chinesischen Staatschef reden wird
zum NATO-Mitglied Polen ist heute der
ukrainische Präsident selenski gereist
es ist sein erster offizieller Besuch in
dem Land Polen hat die meisten
ukrainischen geflüchteten aufgenommen
und ist eine der lautesten Stimmen in
der EU für eine noch umfangreichere
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
auch weil es in Polen selbst die Sorge
gibt von Russland angegriffen zu werden
über den Besuch selenskys berichtet
Natalie Steger
es ist ein Vorvertrag der beiden Seiten
dient der ukrainische Präsident und
polensministerpräsident besiegeln am
Abend den Verkauf von 100 radpanzern aus
polnischer Produktion an die Ukraine
außerdem verspricht Polen weiter
politische Hilfe der Platz des mutigen
ukrainischen Volkes ist in der NATO und
in der EU
an diesem Tag der polnischen Regierung
auch deshalb ist er hier
am Morgen die Begrüßung bei Präsident
duda in Anwesenheit der First Ladies
herzlichst selensky hat mit Polen längst
einen Sprachrohr für seine Forderungen
gefunden Warschau prescht regelmäßig vor
drängt auf mehr Militärhilfe fürs
Nachbarland laduda hat Polen bereits
acht Kampfjets des Typs Mick 29
überstellt und will nachlegen
wir sind bereit ich habe es den
Präsidenten gesagt außerdem sechs
weitere zu übergeben das ist in
Vorbereitung
auch wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
verbunden mit einem Blick in die
erhoffte Zukunft
es ist sehr wichtig für uns das Polen
einer der wichtigsten Partner wird beim
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine am Abend trifft
sich selensky auch mit
Kriegsflüchtlingen im Warschauer Schloss
und spricht gemeinsam wie du da zur
Bevölkerung im Innenhof übertragen mit
Videoleinwänden auf den Schlossplatz
schauen wir nach Israel dort wächst die
Sorge vor einer Eskalation nachdem die
israelische Polizei gestern Nacht die
al-axam Moschee auf dem Tempelberg
gestürmt hat laut Polizei hatten
Palästinenser sich dort vor barrikadiert
rund 350 Menschen wurden festgenommen
als Reaktion flogen wenige Stunden
später Raketen aus dem Gazastreifen
Richtung Israel die Regierung antwortete
mit einem Gegenangriff
bei einer jeden Tag machen sich
Flüchtlinge auf den Weg nach Europa
meist übers gefährliche Mittelmeer und
mit dem Ziel Italien
in diesem Jahr kam dort bereits 28.000
Schutzsuchende an das sind mehr als
viermal so viele wie Anfang 2022 die
meisten stammen aus der Elfenbeinküste
aus Guinea sowie Pakistan und Brechen
von Nordafrika aus auf viele
Schiffbrüchiger trinken in diesem Jahr
laut unschätzung schon mehr als 380
Menschen von Italiens Insel Lampedusa
berichtet Andreas poste
es ist die bereits zweite Ankunft an
diesem Tag kurz hintereinander mehr als
60 Migranten haben die gefährliche
Passage übers Mittelmeer geschafft die
medizinische Erstversorgung übernimmt
das landing emergency Team rund um Dr
Francesco Dakar er bereitet sich auf
anstrengende Monate vor wer bis sah ihr
gebärmelona die Warnungen die uns
vorliegen verheißen nichts Gutes ich
hoffe dass die Befürchtungen nicht
zutreffen dass eine große Anzahl von
Migranten die auf bis zu 400.000
geschätzt wird bereit ist von Tunesien
auszustarten das wäre für uns ein
Problem
denn das Erstaufnahme Camp auf Lampedusa
ist ausgelegt für nur 400 Personen im
Hotspot selbst dürfen wir nicht drehen
Aufnahmen die uns zugespielt werden
zeigen die beengten Zustände die
regelmäßig dann auftreten wenn sehr
viele Menschen auf einmal kommen vor
anderthalb Wochen waren es in nur 48
Stunden über 3.000 die rechtsgerichtete
Regierung Italiens waren getreten die
illegale Migration zu bekämpfen die
vielen Ankünfte und Stresstest für
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni zivile
Seenotretter fordern nun eine neue
gemeinsame europäische
seenotrettungsmission
es braucht ein klares Bekenntnis der
Seenotrettung es braucht ein klares
Bekenntnis dazu das Zusammenarbeit
zwischen seenotrettungsleitstellen der
Küstenwache und zivilen
seenotrettungsorganisationen
vorangebracht wird um auf Lampedusa für
Entlastung zu sorgen werden MigrantInnen
nun auf die Fähre gebracht es ist eine
Durchgangsstation auf dem Weg nach
Europa hier von Lampedusa aus dem Hafen
werden 190 Migranten ausgeschifft ans
Festland mit der Fähre und Platz zu
machen im Camp für Neuankömmlinge die
man in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
hier erwartet im Schulterschluss mit
Europa versucht Italien nun verstärkt
den Migrationsdruck speziell aus
Tunesien abzumildern
nach Deutschland weniger arbeiten und
dabei gleich viel verdient genau das
fordert die IG Metall für die kommenden
Tarifrunde konkret geht es der
Industriegewerkschaft um eine vier Tage
Woche mit 32 Stunden Arbeitszeit bei
vollem Lohnausgleich die Arbeitgeber
lehnen das ab die Forderung käme
Angesicht steigender Kosten zur Unzeit
einem internationalen Ermittlerteam ist
dein bedeutender Schlag gegen
Cyberkriminelle gelungen bei Razzien in
mehreren Ländern konnten die Behörden
rund 120 Verdächtige festnehmen allein
in Deutschland fanden Durchsuchungen bei
58 Beschuldigten statt im Fokus stand
die kriminelle Verkaufsplattform Genesis
market die weltweit größte dieser Art
inzwischen wurde sie vom FBI geschlossen
auf Genesis market wurde unter anderem
mit Kreditkartendaten Zugangsdaten zum
Online-Banking und Passwörtern gehandelt
etwa für E-Mail-Accounts oder Social
Media Profile die Daten wurden meist mit
Schadsoftware ausgesperrt
in Stuttgart hat ein Prozess gegen einen
sogenannten Reichsbürger begonnen
verhandelt wird im streng gesicherten
prozessgebäude des Oberlandesgerichts im
Stadtteil Stammheim dem Angeklagten wird
unter anderem mehrfacher versuchter Mord
vorgeworfen im badischen Boxberg soll er
vor einem Jahr mit einem
Schnellfeuergewehr auf Polizisten
geschossen haben die seine Wohnung
durchsuchen wollten zwei von ihnen
wurden verletzt
ja so sieht das ja ganz entspannt aus
aber nicht alle sind glücklich mit den
E-Scootern Paris hat er jetzt als erste
europäische Großstadt ein Verbot der
leyroller beschlossen und auch hier
wieder eine Debatte entfacht höhere
Bußgeld und Alkoholverbot fordert die
Gewerkschaft der Polizei feste
abstellbereiche der Städte und
Gemeindebund Petra Neubauer hat sich in
München umgehört
sind sie die trendigen Helfer bei der
mobilitätswende oder nur ein lästiges
Ärgernis an den E-Scootern scheiden sich
so manche Geister man kann von A nach B
ganz schnell kommen recht kostengünstig
und einfach bequem
überall untereinander die fahren wie die
Wilden fahren die durch
rücksichtsloses Fahren und gedankenloses
abstellen die Zahl der Beschwerden in
München ist immens rund 13.000 Roller
gibt es in der Stadt verbieten will der
Oberbürgermeister zwar noch nichts aber
es sieht dringenden Handlungsbedarf ich
habe schon deutlich davor gefahren wenn
es so weitergeht dass wir darüber
nachdenken müssen ob er mindestens die
Zahl reduzieren der Angeboten ist guter
bis hin dann tatsächlich auch darüber
nachzudenken wo wir die Benutzung
zulassen und nicht um das wildparken in
den Griff zu bekommen hat die Stadt
bereits 43 spezielle rollerparkplätze
eingerichtet nur dort ist die Rückgabe
des Guten
und auch die Anbieter werden stärker in
die Pflicht genommen zum Beispiel bitten
wir alle nutzenden am Ende der Fahrt ein
Foto zu machen um so zu belegen dass das
Fahrzeug am Ende der Miete auch
ordnungsgemäß abgestellt wurde da die
E-Scooter aber einfach bewegt und
ungepackt werden können es für uns als
Anbieter nicht immer eindeutig
nachweisbar dass der letzte Benutzer
auch Verursacher war nun liegt es also
vor allem an denen die die E-Scooter so
gerne nutzen ob die flottenroller in
München eine Zukunft haben oder nicht
kommen wir zum DFB-Pokal und wer hätte
das gedacht Norbert die Bayern sind raus
aus der Traum vom Triple in dieser
Saison und die erste Niederlage gleich
im zweiten Spiel für Münchens neuen
Trainer Thomas Tuchel ja das ist schon
heftig Freiburg 2:1 last minute für die
Erfolgs hungrigen Bayern ein echter
Schock den Handschlag von Freiburg
Trainer Streich schlägt er aus zu tief
der Frust bei Jamal museala über seine
Hand Spiel das beschert den Freiburgern
durch höher als Elfmeter in der fünften
Minute in der Nacht Spielzeit den Sieg
beim Topf Favoriten das ist jedes mal
super bitte aufs neues zu akzeptieren es
geht mir mehr weder einzelne Lehren in
Niederlage so Opa americano mit robusten
Körpereinsatz vor dem 1:0 die Freiburger
protestieren vergeblich sein aufstützen
und höflers strammer und platzierte
Schuss zum Ausgleich all das nur ein
langes Vorspiel zum dramatischen
Schlussakkord habe
soll uns jetzt auch mal gegönnt sein
dass man mal einmal gewinnen der erste
Freiburger Sieg
im Vieh bei den Bayern er hinterlässt
extrem gegensätzliche Gefühle
im zweiten Viertelfinalspiel gestern
Abend besiegte Frankfurt Union Berlin
mit 2:0 ja und gleich noch so ein echter
viertelfinalkracher der BVB Tabellen
zweiter tritt bei RB an dem Tabellen
fünften Sven Voss in Leipzig eine
Begegnung auf Augenhöhe
ja Norbert sind aber auch zwei
Mannschaften die am vergangenen
Wochenende in der Bundesliga einen
Dämpfer hinnehmen mussten Leipzig
verliert zu Hause gegen Mainz und die
Bayern schlagen Borussia Dortmund mit
vier zu zwei und es wird also heute für
beide Mannschaften ein Charakter Test im
DFB-Pokal Viertelfinale und wenn wir in
die Dortmunder Kabine schauen dann sehen
wir das Gregor Kobel wieder von Anfang
an Spielen wird und er ist derjenige der
heute zeigen kann dass das besser kann
als vergangenen Wochenende gegen die
Bayern es geht um den Einzug ins
Halbfinale Leipzig gegen Dortmund ab
8:15 Uhr geht's los hier im ZDF danke
schön bis gleich dann
Wahlen bei der UEFA Alexander jefferin
wurde als Präsident des Europäischen
Fußballverbands ohne Gegenkandidat
bestätigt
DFB-Chef Bernd Neuendorf wird Mitglied
im FIFA counsel und DFL
Aufsichtsratschef Hans-Joachim Watzke im
UEFA Exekutivkomitee dafür hatte auch
die Norwegerin niese klarvenes
kandidiert konnte sich aber gegen ihre
männlichen Mitbewerber nicht durchsetzen
so schade eigentlich
Norbert und hier noch die Lottozahlen
die Gewinnzahlen lauten vier sechs
fünfzehn 29 41 47 Superzahl ist die 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
beim Wetter ist Sonnenschein angesagt
allerdings kommt auch neue Regen mehr
dazu gleich von Essen
heute schon mal mit Christian Sievers
können Sie gegen 21:35 Uhr sehen in der
Pause des Viertelfinales des DFB-Pokals
tschüss
[Musik]